China has the most extensive network building
and deploying the fifth generation of cellular
networks.
5G runs up to 100 times faster than 4G.
It has built 1.6 million 5G base stations
across the country, according to the state-run
People’s Daily.
In comparison, the U.S. has only about 100,000.
Yet, instead of trailing China, the Americans
could have been the leader in 5G development
had an immigrant been allowed to stay in the
country.
Erdal Arikan may not be a household name.
Yet he’s so extraordinary that Chinese telecom
giant Huawei rolled out the red carpet for
him at its headquarters in Shenzhen in 2018.
They treated him like a rock star because
he developed the fundamental technology for
5G.
Arikan was born and raised in Turkey, the
son of a doctor and a stay-at-home mom.
He loved science and studied electrical engineering
at Middle East Technical University in Ankara.
While in his first year, in 1977, Arikan’s
high test scores allowed him to transfer to
the California Institute of Technology, known
as CalTech, one of the world’s top universities
with a strong focus on science and engineering.
While there, he took a particular interest
in information theory…a study of mathematical
laws that govern communications, including
5G networks.
Information theory was developed a few decades
earlier by the brilliant Claude Shannon at
AT&T’s research arm Bell Labs.
His ideas laid the groundwork for the digital
revolution.
He made the internet possible.
In 1948, Shannon published a mathematical
theory that showed how to transmit messages
accurately at the fastest speed possible.
Say, Scott wants to send a message to Sarah.
A transmitter encodes information into a signal,
which is corrupted by noise and then decoded
by the receiver.
Shannon’s theory showed how to calculate
the maximum rate at which messages can be
sent with zero errors to ensure that the message
Scott sent is the same one Sarah received.
According to Shannon, every communications
channel has a “speed limit” for transmitting
information reliably, referred to as the “Shannon
limit”.
However, Shannon did NOT provide a technique
for constructing the code to achieve the fastest
rate possible or make it clear how to compile
such code.
That’s where Arikan came in.
After graduating from CalTech, he took his
interest in Shannon’s theory to MIT for
his grad studies.
His mentor there, Professor Robert Gallager
was a renowned pioneer in information theory
who came close to the Shannon limit but never
reached it.
Arikan would throw himself into this work
for the next twenty years, trying to attain
what no one had yet been able to do.
After finishing his doctoral thesis in 1986,
he briefly served as an assistant professor
at the University of Illinois at Urbana-Champaign.
However, he was reportedly unable to obtain
a permanent academic post in the U.S. or funding
to continue his work on information theory.
And as a foreign citizen, he had to find an
American employer interested in supporting
him in order to remain in the country.
But he failed to do so…and had no choice
but to return to Turkey.
He once told Wired the reason scientists and
engineers in the U.S. don’t spend decades
working on the same problem is “Because
they wouldn't be able to get tenure; they
wouldn't be able to get research funding.”
He returned to Turkey to join the country’s
first private, non-profit research institution,
Bilkent University - now a leading institution
in the country.
He established its engineering school and
gave lectures and published papers.
But the Shannon limit kept nagging at him.
How do you transmit messages accurately at
the fastest speed possible?
Messages that you send - letters and emojis
- are converted into a string of ones and
zeroes called bits.
The problem is noise can distort the message,
so redundancies are required to make sure
the correct message is received.
Redundancies ensure that if an error does
creep in, you can still be sure of the correct
string and what the original message intended
to say.
However, there is a trade-off: the more redundancies
you add the slower the transmission rate.
So, how did you get around that problem?
After working on it for over two decades,
Arikan had a EUREKA moment in late 2005.
His solution was to make a copy of the channel
and transfer the noise from one channel to
the other, so you’re left with one noisy
channel, and the other that’s much cleaner.
The noise-free channel could in theory reach
the Shannon limit.
He dubbed his discovery: “polar codes”
In reference to banishing noise to the North
Pole, so that there is clear communication
at the South Pole.
He continued to tinker with his discovery,
and in 2009, he published his findings in
the field’s top scientific journal, to much
fanfare.
Arikan tried to sell the idea of polar codes
to both Qualcomm and Seagate, but they declined.
No American company was interested in his
ideas!
He blamed himself for not being a good enough
salesperson, telling Wired:
“I was an academic who did not know how
to promote an idea.
Perhaps I did not believe in the idea that
strongly myself.”
But one company did believe in the idea very
strongly.
The head honchos at Huawei saw the potential
of polar codes.
They believed it was the breakthrough needed
to leap from 4G networks to 5G.
Polar codes are considered a direct challenge
to the American-developed coding method "LDPC"
and are believed to be superior to it.
The Chinese company bet big on polar codes
– investing hundreds of millions of dollars
to build on Arikan’s work.
In fact, when Canadian tech giant Nortel went
under, Huawei poached its top researcher who
grew up in China.
Wen Tong would head Huawei’s R&D division
on 5G.
Huawei’s engineers came up with the software
to make polar codes work in practice and invented
some of the first 5G technologies.
Today, Huawei holds the majority of polar
code patents for 5G and has positioned itself
as a world leader in tech innovation.
Western countries insist Huawei’s technology
may intentionally contain security holes that
could be used by the Chinese government for
spying…which Huawei flatly denies.
The U.S. has banned its equipment.
Despite the tension between the east and the
west over the development of 5G technology,
Arikan is thankful that his tireless work
and refusal to give up…has finally paid
off.
As engineers, there is no greater reward than
seeing our ideas turn into reality.
Thank you for making it happen.
Engineers like Arikan are shaping the world
of tomorrow.
If you’d like to hone your STEM skills so
you can build a product that has the potential
to impact a tremendous number of people, Brilliant
is a great way to brush up on your science,
technology, engineering, and math skills.
Their courses are super interactive.
I know my viewers love the computer science
fundamentals course which helps strengthen
your knowledge of core computer science concepts
and no coding is required.
You can solve puzzles with science through
their scientific thinking course, start your
algebra journey with an introduction to variables
and equations, or see fractions, percentages,
and ratios in everyday contexts with their
Everyday Math course.
There’s something for everyone no matter
your experience level - whether you’re a
student or you’re working and want to brush
up on what you already know.
There are no tests and if you ever get stuck,
you can view the explanation for more.
Brilliant is FREE for you to try out if you
head to the custom link in my description
or pinned comment: brilliant.org/newsthink.
The first 200 people to click my link will
get 20% off the annual Premium subscription
which gives you unlimited access to all of
their offerings.
Thanks for watching.
For Newsthink, I’m Cindy Pom